what continent is India in
what I don't know in India the is a
continent you can tell who got an F in
geography class what is capital city of
Australia oh that would be Sydney Sydney
Australia
Cur what flag is that is that New York
what flag is that that is not Australia
Mexico or N I don't think that's Mexico
that's uh it's France or some somebody
in my chat tell me what kind of
country is this what country is this
what I know this one I did the tests of
finding all the states excuse with the
capitals Alabama youus na wait why are
you even comparing the two isn't na a
country and EU like you want to run that
back
[Music]
Canada